so let's say you just realize that you
have lost or deleted data on your Mac
well this video is going to show you
multiple ways to recover that data
including accidental deletion off of
things like SD cards or external hard
drives or the internal drive as well so
before I get into the best ways to
recover your lost data let's go through
the more simple methods first now the
first method to recover data is very
simple in fact it might be a little bit
funny or obvious to you tech savvy
people out there but let's say you
accidentally deleted a bunch of files
just like I did right there you've got
to check the trash bin yes it could be
in there and this is the easiest way to
recover it be sure you don't empty it
when you don't need to because then it
is going to be gone and you're gonna
have to resort to some other methods
that I'm gonna get into but right now if
it's in the trash bin it's easy to
recover just select it and then right
click and then click put back
there you go it just showed up back onto
the desktop the simplest and most easy
way to do it but let's say you actually
did empty the trash bin there you go it
looks like it's gone forever well there
are some other methods the next method I
want to get into is a time machine
backup so the way you find that is to go
into these settings then basically type
in time machine into the search there
you go we have time machine and as you
can see we don't have a backup disk set
up but if you did have one set up from
the past you can actually go grab it
plug it in and then access your data or
restore a ton of data that you had
previously backed up that is another
method and it could be a lifesaver if
you lost a bunch of data and now moving
on to the third method we have the
iCloud Drive which could be set up with
syncing to your desktop or other folders
on your Mac and let's say you deleted
some things off of your Mac and it was
also deleted off of your iCloud drive as
well which seems like a nightmare
scenario but there is actually a
solution what you're going to do is go
to
icloud.com then go up to your name or
account in the corner then go to account
settings then go down to the bottom of
the list and you'll find in the advanced
section the restore files link so just
click right there it's going to go ahead
and search for recoverable files and if
there are some files that were recently
deleted from the iCloud drive and your
Mac they should show up here and you can
restore them you can see that we can
also restore some contacts and some
calendar events as well and if none of
those methods work this is one we've got
to bring out the big guns and that's
where our sponsor Stellar data recovery
comes in which does an amazing job at
recovering lost or corrupted data now as
you can see here it can scan everything
and the latest version actually can scan
the drive 40 to 50 percent faster than
the previous version and it supports
features like recovering data from M1
and M2 Chip enabled Max as well as the
drive monitor feature to check hard
drive Health as you can see right here
100 performance 100 Health good temps
it's passing the smart status check we
could basically see everything here
including the power on Cycles basically
everything about the storage that's a
nice additional feature but the main one
we want is the actual data recovery for
stuff like hard drives the internal
drive or SD cards and if you're
wondering which scenario Stellar data
recovery can help you with first of all
it's available for both Mac and windows
and it can help you with accidental
deletion emptying of trash like we did
earlier formatting of the wrong external
drive imagine that maybe improper Drive
ejection where you lose data
unfortunately or if your external drive
isn't mounting properly maybe you have
missing files inside of your actual time
machine backup maybe you deleted files
from your iCloud drive and it's past the
restore period or you overwritten some
of your old data and you need to recover
it and by the way seller actually has an
article that I'll leave a link to down
in the description below for how to
recover data in all of these situations
with step-by-step information just in
case you need a little bit of help so
check that out if you need to but with
that said let's actually show you an
example of how this can recover data we
have SD cards and we film a lot of
videos here and sometimes we've had
issues where we've accidentally deleted
important video clips especially doing
like a Hands-On comparison it gets
deleted and what do you do you have to
resort to It software like Stellar data
recovery so let me just plug this into
the SD card slot there you go it's
refreshing the drive list and it should
detect it right here here there you go
we have our Untitled SD card slot but
first let's actually delete the data off
of this card we have some thumbnail
images here that we took recently you
can see right there and we also have
some video clips as well these could be
very important so let's go ahead delete
them and I'll show you that I'm going to
empty the trash as well there you go
it's deleted trash is emptied the card
has nothing on it and now let's go
through this software so basically we're
going to select the SD card right here
and then click scan wow that's fast
that is super fast to scanning there you
go it found a bunch of files so let's go
to the file list
photos
look at that we have our Raw photos
and oh it's able to see them too look at
that preview is enabled look wow it's
able to see it there you go it looks
like we have everything back that is
awesome let's go to the videos and look
at that we have our videos as well that
is awesome and there you go we have our
folder right there we can go into the
private and look at that our four videos
show up they were recovered so with that
said definitely use the links below to
check out Stellar data recovery because
it can be a huge help and recover your
lost or deleted files so with that said
click the circle button to subscribe and
check out one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
foreign